I went to the arcade in Japan to try out
every single game Japan is famous for
their arcades but I need to find out
which ones are actually worth your time
and which ones are just complete garbage
my name is beanie pack and I'm here to
find out what's the greatest game in the
arcade
here we go
today feels like a weird dream come true
if I told my 15 year old self I was
gonna do this I would not believe it
coming into the arcade I was prepared I
had looked up online and the first game
I wanted to try out was Arsenal base but
before I could start gaming I knew there
was one thing I needed the arcade card
so I want to get one of these cards with
the arcade card you can charge it up so
you don't have to keep spending coins
and you get offers to special deals
Japan loves cards way too much I already
have way too many but I know I wanted
this one but most importantly you get to
save all your progress I want the
virtual anime babies to say welcome back
not welcome for some reason in my head I
thought this would be really hard to get
turns out all you have to do is give 300
Yen to the machine which is like two
bucks and that's it isn't that easy it
is that easy you also get one free game
at every machine so 100 worth it so the
first one I wanna
[Music]
hey remember that one time I said Japan
loves cards
this game is all about cards you place
your physical cards in front of you and
they appear in game yeah honestly I
think that's so cool I wish more games
would follow that suit
the goal of the game is to destroy the
enemy's base you deploy your Gundam by
dragging them out on the screen
using their special abilities
this is cool I like this game
the special abilities were a little bit
fiddly but being a Pro Gamer of course I
nailed it every single time no it's
starting to understand the strategy a
little bit sometimes how much do you get
to play just from one coin
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know what was going on the
entire time but putting this in a tier
next up was ungeeki this is a rhythm
game with anime girls in it
hooray it's a simple rhythm game you hit
the notes by pressing the buttons while
simultaneously moving the joystick to
collect points and I don't I don't know
I don't know what I'm doing
but I love it
no honestly it's a pretty fun random
game as you can tell I'm having a blast
I'm gonna go ahead and put this in beat
here and hope the weebs don't kill me
for it next up is tunith Sun I was
really excited to play it because every
time I see it it's always packed with
people playing it this has to be good
it starts up pretty simple and introduce
you to the game one of its main
mechanics is this sensing range that
detects your hand if you pull it up or
down it's a bit awkward at first but
once you get into it it's actually
pretty cool I switch up to advanced mode
and pick the most degenerate song I
could possibly find
okay I get what this game is popular
it's honestly super fun you feel great
just mashing your hands at a keyboard I
mean just look at it I've been playing
for three minutes and it's just so
satisfying
[Music]
I love that maybe a bit too much
maybe ladies and gentlemen our first s
tier switching game to Nostalgia op3
this is a rhythm game that heavily
mimics the piano and going from tune his
son where I just can Mash keys and not
think about it
somehow doing it on what replicates the
piano made me feel like an adult baby
just like mashing buttons I hated this
game
this game sucks maybe because I suck at
the game but that doesn't matter
Nostalgia op3 you belong in the trash
next up sound Vortex exceed gear
I like that like most Rhythm games it
starts off simple just hit buttons you
also have to worry about hitting the
ones in the back so it's a little bit
more complicated but the main Crux is
adjusting the volume slide
[Music]
it's a pretty good Game it makes you
feel like you're a scuff DJ or something
like that
too much confidence and switched up the
difficulty and oh my God
let's just rate it high and pretend that
didn't happen next up I tried Wonder
Wars this game has a pen
this is an RPG based game and after
skipping about 600 dialogues and
promotions I could finally play it you
can throw your character with a compass
in the middle then draw with your pen to
use your attacks
and then you win
yes
honestly not sure what you think about
this game I think if you spend a lot of
time in it it could probably be pretty
cool I don't know I looked up gameplay
online just because I was curious and it
looks a lot cooler on higher level it's
basically a MOBA I don't know why that
didn't register so maybe it is good but
I didn't see a single person play it the
entire time I was there I honestly can't
rate it higher than this after that it
was time for a break it's intense in
there that's to get a break to be honest
entering again I realize there's a whole
section I missed downstairs God damn it
I gotta play all of these Pokemon
messages
again I come prepared I had bought
physical Pokemon tokens to this kid's
game yes I am that pathetic
it did not feel right sitting alone in
the Kids Corner playing this game alone
[Music]
you activate your Pokemon by sliding it
up and then you're supposed to press the
buttons that's what I did at least and
oh boy did I price
I am not losing at a kids game
I'll set a kid's game
that's all I have
I'm way too old for this [ __ ] I would be
concerned if anyone the same as my age
would rate it higher than this next up
taikono tatsujin Kids Corner or not this
game is [ __ ] awesome you've
definitely seen this game before it's a
basic drum game this game is so much fun
to play with a friend as well I highly
recommend it if you've never done it
before and honestly even playing it
alone was really fun because the songs
are so good
but alas it was time to move on it's a
classic arcade game has to be an S tier
dance Rush stardom by now the arcade had
gotten more busy and I was dreading
playing this game alone in front of
people
definitely regretting saying I was gonna
play every single game by now this game
doesn't have buttons like Dance Dance
Revolution but it looks pretty sad you
just press down with your legs on the
Arrow when it tells you to
and you also get to go down and up
I actually hate this I pretty much felt
as cool as I look here
and it saves this cool video of you yay
all in all it was not bad and if I was
playing with someone else I would
definitely play it again I never ever
want to do that again
yeah yeah next up kankore arcade how do
I describe this game I don't know the
entire time I was there I was the only
one who played it first off you pick
your anime girl I decided this one then
actually they print out a card for you
with it
kind of cool then you put it in and
something happens it's like a battleship
game but with anime girls and you fight
all these weird sea monsters
[Music]
surprisingly the game was not that bad
come on
[Music]
but the more I played the game just got
weirder and weirder what the [ __ ] is
that
we could have all these type of games
I'd be lying if I said this one wasn't
actually that bad quisnock Stadium a
Japanese quiz game what could go wrong
this game is very serious it even has an
esport element to it you play
competitively against other players
online the most fun I had was spamming
emotes in the lobby with strangers
but it was all downhill from there turns
out I'm just that bad at Japanese
sorry quiznok not even the emotes can
save you Initial D racing baby oh yeah
it's drifting time pick the best car
there is and then started drifting away
don't know if there's that much to say
about a racing game I definitely think
it's more fun if you play with friends
it does have a story mode which seems
pretty good and I did beat him at this
very last second so hey there's that
let's go ahead and put it in B it's a b
not a d
extreme 2x boost I felt a bit
embarrassed playing this because they
were always packed and I had to wait for
my turn to play and once it was my turn
to play I had no [ __ ] clue what I was
doing it is a Gundam fighting game where
you play against other players online it
looks cool when other people are playing
it but not me so I'm sorry this is all I
got I saw the game is out on PS4 so
maybe I'll check that out and I'll come
back with more confidence I'll give it a
B for now because it looks really cool
ah that might be a little bit generous
actually it's waka waka time I played
this game before and I was so excited to
try it out again it's a rhythm game very
similar to tune his son if feels so cool
to have the controls all around you
I think these kind of games are so
unique to the arcade you have to play to
experience it I actually love it I would
give it an S fate Grand order arcade it
took me so long to figure out how to
play because I had to press the screen
itself to wake up the machine
I'm so confused
but I was running kind of low on time at
this point so all I can tell is I use
this Christmas girl special move attack
and it was very cool
wait there's a photo
not on me sorry fate fans this game
looks good but I don't know if I care to
find out if it is my my diraksu Festival
yeah another rhythm game it's a really
fun one to play with someone else you've
seen me in March I play it in the Vlogs
every goddamn time I play this game I
mess up skipping the tutorial and it's
so painstakingly slow
yeah because of that I jumped straight
into expert and oh my god I've actually
seen people play this game as if they're
doing a workout and I can totally see
why Jesus Christ I was considering
giving it an expert tutorial you pissed
me up getting towards the end now
resident Beat Mania to the x30 also a
bit awkward because you have to descend
on this Podium to play it as far as
rhythm game goes it's pretty damn simple
but they all start off simple so I don't
know you either hit the notes or you hit
the scratchy thing there was not enough
scratchy things I was disappointed this
has to be an older game he played songs
from a genre I had forgotten even
existed
[Music]
it would probably be fun to stand up
there with someone else but alone it
just felt kind of sad
I like the music but I don't see myself
playing this over the others last but
not least star horse 4. I wasn't
actually even gonna play this game but I
felt like I had to
it's a digital horse betting game
I'm writing business and apparently
that's exactly what they were going with
the seats were massive it takes place in
a different room in the arcade as well
and I gotta say it was really [ __ ]
comfortable sitting in there problem is
my arcade card wasn't working and I
didn't understand what I was doing wrong
I tried looking online and I just got
more confused I had gotten a piece of
heaven sitting in those chairs at this
point I needed to play this game turns
out I just had to go downstairs and in
my epic Japanese ass to register I just
had to fill in a form take a photo of
myself and give away my fingerprint
which was kind of weird and I had to
promise not to drink and smoke
I was in you get to adjust your seat
just like the trailer it was only me and
another Japanese person in the room and
I really felt out of place being there
it is a gambling game so I had to spend
a bit more money on this one the
interface had so much to click on and I
didn't know where to start but I finally
played some battle number five red
Rapids
the race was off and I was already
starting off second last
I thought for sure I was toast I
couldn't even see rep is razuri on the
screen at this point
you had to be in the room to believe it
I honestly couldn't believe it it was so
funny rabbis razuli pulled through
I hit the Super Jackpot first try oh my
God
to top off the weirdness of this
experience after the race they sang what
sounded like Celine Dion My Heart Will
Go On but sung in Japanese
but remember it came gambling is banned
quit while you're ahead and if you go
positive ones you win for life I had
officially played all games it was time
to head back home
ah had so much fun
oh yeah star horse 4 easiest here these
were all the games in my Arcane if I
didn't play your favorite maybe I'll
save it for next one smash like
subscribe